Suge knight gear for La.
I mean,
I feel like this is probably the more conscious,
we didn't do anything to women,
but you know,
like friends who worked with them and say like,
Hey,
we're going out.
You want to come out now I'm going to go back and check off.
Like,
yeah,
it just,
it was just into watching porn and beaten off all the time.
Well,
I think I was talking about,
because we both know him.
Louis,
since you've known him since 1989 probably.
I don't,
I never knew anybody or wound them.
I,
I would see him like once a year,
twice a year,
somewhere in say hi.
Um,
I know you way better than I know him.
Yeah.
Uh,
the,
so I remember when I moved to New York and 91 and was in the comedy club scene
in 92 93 94 in New York.
I was,
I couldn't believe the amount of jerking off that was going on.
I just remember her like,
why is everyone constantly talking about like,
what the fuck is going to Louie's apartment four to shoot,
uh,
movies like his shorts that he used to make.
I would like pa on them and uh,
and it always smelled gross.
Like Jay Moore was constantly,
Jay Moore,
we're in,
me and I were roommates for a bit.
He jerked off on one of my socks.
Like,
just like,
like why is everyone jerking off all the time?
Just like,
what is the,
what the fuck is happening?
That's rape.
Yeah.
No,
you know what's funny is I was wondering like today,
yeah,
I was thinking about the thing,
the Jay thing again,
cause I'm,
I'm of the mind,
like
again,
Louie was more gross than,
than uh,
malicious and discuss malicious and criminal.
I just gross that what he did.
I think it was good.
It wasn't clear.
Okay.
He did it to a man.
It takes on more ominous tones when he's doing it to women.
Completely agree.
Yeah.
Uh,
it's,
I mean,
I'm not,
I don't know if it's not a crime,
right?
No,
no,
no.
I don't think so.
No,
I think it's just sad.
It's nothing like Cosby.
It's just pathetic.
It's weird.
And you know,
I had some conversations with
uh,
Eliza slessinger.
She was saying that men would say things to her when she first started.
Doc,
she wasn't very good.
You know,
she just started out and these guys were like established guys and they would
treat her as if like you're below me and you're always going to be below me and
I can get away with saying whenever I want to you,
cause you're less than me.
And she goes and I kind of feel like that's probably why he did that to those
girls.
Like he was above them,
they were below him and it was not just,
hey,
I want to jerk off in front of you.
It's like you have to watch me jerk off because I'm above you.
You know what's the thing you said earlier?
It was relevant,
which is getting hard right from that.
How can you,
yeah,
that's the thing that's like,
but I,
but then it's also like you don't pick your kinks and all that shit.
Like,
yeah,
you don't pick that.
Yeah,
that's even a direct correlation.
Most kinks are just like,
I don't know,
I'm jogging like uh,
being hung off the roof.
Everybody,
you know what I mean?
Like
uh,
but yeah,
that's the thing of like the,
the getting hard thing but also a
fuck I the whole thing.
It is sad.
It's fucked up.
But I actually think he'll be,
he'll be in a year and a half.
He'll be back stronger than ever.
Yeah.
Cause now he's got something to talk about for.
Yeah,
it's to,
it's going to be a lot of dudes at the show.
It's going to be 90% dudes.
But I've asked the crowd,
I've asked probably five or six different crowds.
If Louis was doing the show after this,
would you go and 70% of the people will plug?
Yeah.
They would want to see what the fuck he has to say.
Yes.
I think he should go on stage.
The first words out of his mouth should be,
well I asked I there's,
I believe light should just come up and he's jerking off.
Yeah,
that's a great idea.
And I'm just like,
lights down and just like,
yeah,
I think what he did was freaky and weird,
but I think Louie,
I don't think Louise a monster.
I don't really know him very well,
but I don't,
I don't think he's a bad person.
He's always been friendly to me.
He's not a bad person.
He's not like,
he's not a bad,
he's not.
He's also,
again,
I don't want to be like defending a sex criminal.
If it's a power thing,
he the more powerfully got the lessee did it.
Yeah.
That's the weird thing,
right?
It's like,
I think he realized that what he did was fucked up and like he had these crazy
urges and he did it and then as time went on,
he stopped doing it and he's like,
I'm a prisoner to some shit that I know
just got in front of it.
I feel like if he had just real a,
if he had just talked about it in a letter,
men talked about fucking his staff on the air and no one cared.
Well,
Letterman just went straight.
You mean a hundred percent confessional?
Yeah.
Which I think Louie [inaudible],
he just mishandled it.
Liked having sex with the people that work with.
And by the way,
I talked to the lady about this yesterday.
He goes,
you have you watched it.
He's getting laughs the whole time.
Yeah.
Like the whole time I'm getting big labs.
He was brilliant.
Yeah.
I miss him.
But again,
and the other thing,
it's like the irony of like Netflix didn't pull his show.
Yeah.
But he was only having sex with people.
But here's the thing,
having sex with people back then,
but that you now an abuse of power
that can sit again.
We're talking about four years ago.
That's crazy.
You've got to rate,
it feels like it's changed.
What's changed?
Is it just everyone?
I think the Harvey Weinstein thing was so fucking gross and he's such a monster
that everybody's like completely.
I think there's this ripple effect and that this we're,
we're like way beyond normal reactions for things like Matt Lauer.
I'm still trying to figure out what Matt Lauer did that got him.
He had sex with someone on staff.
Yeah.
I think he had sex with someone on staff that probably felt like she couldn't
stop.
Mm.
That that would be the,
that would be that sort of rub.
I don't know.
You see,
I don't,
I don't want a victim shame.
Right.
You don't know.
You don't know what really happened.
I don't know his version.
I don't even know her version.
I just know the third hand version,
you know,
like I read one that he had sex with some girl until she blacked out and like
Matt Lauer likes to fuck.
Yeah.
He's throwing in his office girl sir.
And then the other thing was that he had a button on his desk.
We can lock the door.
That,
yeah,
that to me is less,
uh,
rape trap then than it is just like a fucking,
I don't want to have to get up and go when you're the opposite [inaudible] big
and you're like,
fuck,
you know,
it's probably,
I don't want to walk 40 feet.
Right.
Every time I need to shut the door.
Well,
it's also,
he's writing right when you,
right.
You don't want to be disturbed.
He just like,
it's rather just let me just lock the fucking door and lock into this thing.
I don't even think he was writing.
I think it's just like a convenience thing maybe.
Um,
but there was no,
um,
the only abuses that he was having sex with someone who was above,
below him.
Right.
It wasn't like he,
you know,
he didn't chase him down like Harvey did or,
offer them a Gig.
Or another friend of mine said some interesting,
which he said,
uh,
until dating people you work with is illegal.
This is never going to stop.
Yeah.
Whitney's got a great joke about that,
that she's doing right now about working in an office,
you know,
cause she works on Roseanne.
No.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's their world,
you know,
it's like,
yeah,
when men and women are in,
yeah.
And you can't,
like,
where else are you going to meet people.